it is the same exact it is the same
exact time everywhere in the universe
like I know you've talked about how the
moon and Space Station is on Houston
time because that's who they talk to but
is the whole of the universe within the
same unit of time at the same time or do
the vast expansion of the universe do
something funky with that yeah I mean
different parts of the University of
moving at different rates and time has
some relative aspects to it so for
example the GPS satellites yeah
the clocks on them tick at a different
rate than clocks on Earth's surface
because when you move far away from the
gravity from a source of gravity yeah
your time speeds up so the clocks on the
GPS satellites are not taking at the
rate that of the clocks that they are
informing down here on earth the
military puts a correction into the
clock time you get from a GPS satellite
so that it matches the time we needed to
have here on the Earth's surface so so
if you're in motion if you're near a
gravity source or far from one your
clock is ticking at a slightly different
time from everybody else's it was then
what time is it on Jupiter well so you
go to Jupiter to set up a good thing oh
you say you set up a time system so the
way you want to answer that in
interesting ways you take two identical
clocks the one on earth and one on
Jupiter and watch what happens the one
on Jupiter will take slower than the one
on earth really because of Jupiter's
gravitational field slows down the
ticking of the clock so is so one way to
live forever is to go to Jupiter and sit
there no you'll just look longer than
you would on earth right right not
forever sorry longer yeah you'll
suffocate and die from bring you bring a
good jar ignoring that combination yes
you go to Jupiter a little slightly
longer than you would here on earth how
much longer actually oh say your life is
a hundred years o minutes or years yeah
no minutes oh that's really not worth it
sorry I got excited you're like yeah you
look for a hundred years
ten minutes oh that's sooner not where
is it it's been I mean off the top of my
head I think it's